Taylor Swift attended the October 1st
Chiefs Jets game at MetLife Stadium with
an Entourage in tow including bestie
Blake Lively Lively's husband Ryan
Reynolds Hugh Jackman and director Sean
Levy Reynolds and Jackman will share the
screen as Deadpool and Wolverine in the
upcoming Deadpool 3 with Levy directing
they could all just be friends hanging
out but there's also a chance Reynolds
could work some magic and get swifter
part in the three quality X-Men's
resident Popstar thus the theory being
spouted by accounts Like mediae Comics
and raps on X formerly known as Twitter
the fan community site posted okay so
seemingly Taylor Swift as dazzler in
Deadpool 3 it's all just a rumor at the
moment but the pieces could be falling
in place for the Swifty and Marvel
fandoms to unite Reynolds has already
proven himself to be Adept at getting
aless cameos and his superhero movies
Deadpool 2 features blink and your
missed appearances from Brad Pit and
Matt Damon so Taylor Swift in Deadpool 3
wouldn't be out of the question
especially considering how close Swift
is with Blake Lively